here here's the top five for the world's  sexiest accents british okay french  italian spanish irish i disagree with  yeah irish i would i would say no on the  irish  actually it's it's cool yeah i think  it's really freaking cool and i love  like listening to it but i don't know if  it's sexy you if you could change your  you like your accent do you like your  american new york accent  are you like that's a coveted accent  i'll take it or do you buy into any of  the little bit of blowback we get  for stereotypical like we sound like  goons i think i sound completely  different in my head than what i  actually sound like when i'm talking i'm  like oh i sound like a tough new yorker  and then when i listen to myself back do  you stand up or watch the podcast i  legitimately sound like like a gay queen  right from like the 1960s you've got a  bit of both going on and i think it's i  think it's endearing